c'est le big boss du système nerveux un
kilo et demi 2 % du poids total de notre
corps deux hémisphères de quatre clubs
chacun trois couches de ménage plus de
85 milliards de neurones vie mille
milliards de connexions nerveuses par
centimètre cube le cerveau c'est tout ça
mais c'est pas tout on voit ça de plus
près avec cette trucs à savoir sur votre
cerveau c'est l'organe le mieux protéger
le cerveau il est enfermé dans un coffre
fort en hausse la boîte crânienne
du coup il est hyper bien protégés
contre les blessures direct mais le
revers de la médaille c'est qu'en cas de
choc il se cogne contre les parois
il peut gonfler ou alors ça peut saigner
et le sens prendre la place le problème
c'est que les eaux n'est pas extensible
du coup le cerveau il est comprimé et
sai meme pas ça c'est un petit gourmand
n'intervint y consomme 15% du débit
cardiaque 20% de notre oxygène et 25% du
glucose corporelle voyez c'est un petit
gourmand est plutôt un bec sucré c'est
pas la taille qui compte bon en vrai
c'est un petit peu plus compliqué que ça
comme tout ce qui touche au cerveau de
manière générale disons que ok la taille
de notre cerveau elle a augmenté au fur
et à mesure de l'évolution en même temps
que nos capacités intellectuelles se
développer mais de manière individuelle
il n'y a aucun lien scientifique qui a
été établi entre la taille du cerveau et
l'intelligence deux exemples d'abord un
les hommes
ils ont en moyenne un cerveau qui est
plus grand que celui des femmes
et pourtant ils n'ont pas de capacités
intellectuelles plus développé ni un qi
plus élevé et 2 albert einstein qui
avait un cerveau plus petit que la
moyenne
donc vous voyez dans l'absolu fauqué la
taille ça compte un peu mais le plus
important c'est la manière dont on s'en
sert sa taille diminue avec l'âge
alors ça oui par contre c'est sur la
taille de notre cerveau elle diminue
quand on vieillit en globalité et aussi
certaines parties spécifiques
alors c'est difficile de faire vraiment
la part des choses mais on estime que
c'est en partie lié au vieillissement
est en partie à certaines maladies comme
la main
10 d'alzheimer par exemple on en utilise
pas que 10% dans la série des bullshit
que tout le monde croit non on n'utilise
pas seulement 10%
notre cerveau on utilise tout juste on
n'utilise pas tous en même temps il se
dessèchent quand on a trop bu quand vous
buvez de l'alcool c'est votre foi qu'il
élimine en très grande partie mais pas
uniquement il ya aussi vos reins et pour
ça ils travaillent plus que d'habitude
résultat vous urinez plus de liquide que
vous n'en buvaient du coup pour pouvoir
fonctionner normalement votre corps il
va aller taper dans les stocks d'eau de
vos différents organes et notamment dans
ceux du cerveau qui se dessèchent
c'est pour ça que le lendemain matin
s'applique il fonctionne à l'envers
c'est la partie droite de votre cerveau
qui commande la partie gauche de votre
corps et inversement
c'est chelou mecenova voilà c'était
cette soul à savoir sur votre cerveau
mais ce qu'il faut surtout savoir c'est
qu'on est encore très loin de tout
comprendre et de tout savoir sur votre
cerveau